okay yesterday Donald Trump held a press
conference it was his day after the
election press conference it was an
utterly and completely embarrassing gong
show but there is one specific part
that's getting the most attention so
some of the things we could talk about
from the press conference include Donald
Trump calling a question about racism
racist Donald Trump was asked about how
he now calls himself a nationalist and
he said that's a racist question what
that means I couldn't tell you he was
particularly hostile to non-white
members of the press but the moment
that's getting the most attention is
when cNN's Jim Acosta asked a reasonably
firm question and Donald Trump started
scolding him a White House intern as
she's now being described tried
physically taking the microphone from
Jim Acosta and now the White House has
decided to pull Jim Acosta's press
credential and they are claiming that
they're doing it because Jim Acosta hit
the White House in turn he laid hands on
the White House intern depending on
which statement you look at all of a
sudden pretending that they're concerned
about violence and aggression against
women which is just the most laughable
thing in the world so let's go through
this piece by piece starting with the
exchange in question if you're listening
you'll be able to hear it if you're
watching you'll be able to also actually
see this sort of entanglement of arms
that takes place which the Trump
administration is now claiming was Jim
Acosta laying hands on a woman the way
that that's not an evasion honestly I
think you should let me run the country
you run CNN or and if you did it well
your ratings let me ask you if I may ask
mr. president I'm
are you worried that's enough that's one
of the other folks that's enough for me
ma'am I'm miss Resnick that's enough
this president I had one of these I may
ask on on the Russia investigation are
you concerned that that you may have not
concerned about anything with you main
investigation because it's a hoax are
you that's enough put down the mic mr.
president are you worried about
indictments coming down in this
investigation
mr. president I'll tell you what CNN
should be ashamed of itself having you
working for them you are a rude terrible
person so there's a few layers to this
what took place is that a White House
intern came over and tried to take the
microphone from Jim Acosta while he was
asking completely normal and reasonable
questions and Donald Trump responded to
the questions by attacking him
personally saying he's a terrible person
or maybe he was the word horrible and
that CNN should be embarrassed that he
works for them and what you may have
noticed is that in the midst of all this
when this White House intern is trying
to physically remove the microphone from
Jim Acosta he actually says pardon me
ma'am and his hand sort of gets
entangled with hers as she enters his
personal space to rip the mic away and
he has the microphone in his right hand
and his left hand gets entangled with
hers so already just on the basis of
this attack against Jim Acosta this
should be perceived as an attack on all
media and every single person in that
press corps should be in total
solidarity with Jim Acosta that's number
one these attacks on the press must stop
but then hours later Trump's just
persistently on dishonest
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
went on Twitter and announced that the
Trump administration is banning Jim
Acosta
from the press corps because he hit a
woman okay she said President Trump
believes in a free press and expects and
welcomes tough questions of him and his
administration we will however never
tolerate a reporter placing his hands on
a young woman just trying to do her job
as
White House intern they are saying that
the problem is that Acosta touched the
woman when clearly she approached a
full-grown man and respected member of
the press corps tried to physically
enforce ibly remove the microphone from
his hands and he said pardon me ma'am
when their hands got tangled up
not exactly a sign of aggression and the
most hypocritical part of this pat is
that they never cared about this issue
and now they're using it to suppress
speech they're not supporting the
Violence Against Women Act they
immediately doubted the allegations of
Brett Kavanaugh as sexual assault
accusers but now Jim Acosta zarm becomes
entangled with the person trying to take
his microphone in a suppression of
speech and they want to frame him as
some kind of domestic abuser yeah when
you watch the video back and we will
again you can see it's much ado about
nothing and IIIi think they are just
trying to get rid of Jim Acosta because
they find him to be a nuisance and if
you notice if you look at the video
she's kind of pulling the mic which
causes one of his hands to pull down you
could make the argument that it's kind
of a natural thing to happen that his
other arm also pulls down and just so
happens to land on her but even going
into that amount of detail I think just
plays into the White House's game well
here is where it gets toxic right-wing
media is agreeing that it costs to hit
the intern and they are partially
defending this using a video that has
been reportedly been doctored and it the
video it's not clear if it was created
or spread by someone associated with
Alex Jones is Infowars I don't even know
that I have to name the guy because he's
so toxic here's the original clip with
audio okay and you'll see the speed at
which things happen and you'll notice
that there is nothing aggressive or
malicious from Jim Acosta particularly
when you hear him say pardon me ma'am as
soon as there's physical contact
that's where the other folks that sit
now for me man and then here is the one
that has been spread by right-wing media
possibly by this Infowars dude and we're
gonna look at it and what you will
notice first of all is that most of the
video has been slowed down and then the
moment that the arm tangle happens the
video goes way faster to comparatively
appear as a karate chop which is
literally what they have been calling it
on Twitter saying that Jim Acosta karate
chopped the White House intern this is
literal fake news and importantly they
remove the sound so that you can't hear
him say pardon me ma'am as the tangle
happens because of course that's also
not the language of an aggressive
wife-beater which is what this edited
version of the video is supposed to
imply and and this subtle editing of the
acosta video by speeding up ever so
slightly that particular moment is
calculated to increase the rage it has
now been watched a hundred thousand
times or more and the fact that it was
doctored doesn't even matter people see
the video as validating what happened as
per sarah huckabee sanders doesn't
matter if the video has been edited it's
now part of the distorted narrative and
for all we know this entire thing was
pre-planned given how the intern started
inching closer and closer and closer to
Jim Acosta as he was asking questions
looking at Trump for some kind of signal
or approval to go and try to physically
grab the mic
these aren't protesters at a rally right
Jim Acosta is a member of the press
corps speaking to the President of the
United States if they lie about this
they will lie about anything we know
that they will lie about anything they
are using all of this the firing of
sessions getting Jim Acosta out of there
not answering questions in a serious way
about the Trump Russian investigation it
is all meant to end the investigation
and they are going beyond what we've
seen so far and in the end this is a
horrible attack on the press but it is
also a distraction from the more
aggressive methods being used to stop
the Trump Russia investigation including
what we started the show with the firing
of recused on Russia Attorney General
Jeff Sessions and we cannot ignore that
one of today's sponsors is Skillshare
which is an amazing online learning
community that offers thousands of high
quality classes on almost any topic the
first 500 people will click the link
under this video we'll get to entire
months of totally free access to every
single class offered by Skillshare
they've got classes on everything design
video editing photography business
technology cooking meditation even
classes on how to become a more
productive person I know you'll be able
to find something on Skillshare that
fascinates you or will help you with
something in your everyday life
classes are taught by real people who
care about what they're teaching I just
took a really great class on more
advanced video editing techniques the
david pakman show is giving you two
months of free access to every class
they offer when you click the link under
this video I mean really just think
about everything that you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free that's hard to beat and
after that if you like it you can keep
having access to every class on
Skillshare for less than ten bucks a
month it's one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of skill share but hurry
because it's only available to the first
500 people who sign up